you and alvino is back this year with a
twist this year we get to go on a
culinary journey that begins tonight and
here to tell us more is chef francesco
and we have joe from anima and also joe
phillips with southern wines welcome you
guys thank you great to be here let's
talk about the grand tasting first
because this is happening on may 7th unl
vino is such an iconic event for las
vegas what can we expect this year yeah
this year very different from in the
past before we used to have it at big
venues there was a lot of like that big
festival atmosphere this year it's much
smaller only 500 tickets available wow
and it's going to be at the hospitality
at the hospitality college so right
there on campus this year yeah right
okay exactly and things are different
too because everything kind of starts
tonight with the grand tasting uh
tonight actually is a dinner at monamiga
beach very exclusive where there's a few
tickets left available tonight at six
o'clock all right that's the kickoff at
monamiga b so it's this food and wine
pairing featuring the wines of chimney
rock
sounds good right there now you
gentlemen have something going on next
month in april yes on april 11th we're
going to do the second of the unlv
tasting to raise funds um by anima by
idio uh so it's located in southwest
part of town at the gramercy uh we have
a 250 tickets are 200 i'm sorry 50
tickets available at 250 ahead um still
some available as well but we'll pair
wines with farniente and nickel and
nickel i love that we're expanding you
and albino it's not just one night
anymore this is now multi-month affair
with food and wine pairings what's some
of the food dishes you guys will have at
your restaurant this one is one of the
courses it's a ricotta and truffle
capatelli with the jamon and peas and we
finish it off with the bone marrow i
mean you could read the ingredients to
anything it would make it sound
appealing i mean it sounds so good right
there does it not wow that sounds like
this is the bone marrow what we have
here what are the benefits of eating
bone marrow i mean aside from it being
adding umami uh and a savory element to
the dish it's you know we scrape it into
it so it's got a little bit of table
side attraction to it and what wines are
you guys pairing it with this one is
with the enroute uh pinot noir from the
farniente nickel and nickel wine company
so that's what we're pairing with that
but you'll also taste the ferny ante
cabernet sauvignon nickel and nickel
cabernet farniente chardonnay what's the
standard is there a standout wine this
year at ionovino the big grand tasting
on the seventh tonight they're i mean
i'll get in trouble
[Laughter]
but
i mean should you have a course of i
want to say attack but of course of
action when you go to you and alvina
where did you start with your res do you
start with your whites what's the best
way to approach a wine tasting uh my own
advice going there a minute is go to the
open table
start with the open tables because the
lines tend to fill up so really that's
just go and enjoy that's like that's
that's the college jc where walking to
you and albino like there's no line over
there let's stand here and taste this
all night long would there be food there
on may 7th yes yes there will fact five
local chef do you you'll be
there by idio will be part of it as
amongst other ones as well which i love
though tonight first night we get our
grand tasting and pairing the food and
everything then you guys are on april
11th should we buy tickets now in
advance for for your tasting yes you can
totally buy tickets right now and then
joe so i mean this year 500 people that
that's an intimate affair yeah that's
the the amend on may 7th because usually
it was like a thousand or so right and
so you know tickets now they're in
advance absolutely buy tickets now
because this is the first you know like
a much more intimate much more um you'll
actually have a chance probably to taste
everything taste the food taste all the
different wines because of the setting
and before how many you and all videos
what was your what was your first one
what year do you remember gosh i don't
remember um but am i i mean i really
haven't been going i've been here for a
long time i'm going to them as a
customer but five or six that i've been
involved with kind of behind the scenes
you remember the first one first so i'm
a unlv grad also so i participated for a
while yes yeah the unlv grads i remember
going back during college yeah it's
really big because all the students get
involved i mean this is and it benefits
the hotel college one of the biggest
fundraisers
for the students i love it thank you
guys we appreciate it all the
information is up on our screen right
now there it is you and alvino buy your
tickets right now at unlv
dot com las vegas now we'll be right
back